bonsoir trois jours de recherches au
zaïre pour un résultat décevant
philippe de dieuleveult et son équipe
sont toujours introuvables les
sauveteurs n'ont récupéré que les deux
embarcations aucune trace de l'équipe
quelques précisions nouvelles ce soir
sur les circonstances de cette
disparition et sur le lieu les rapides
d'inga très dangereux jamais franchie
l'équipe alors résister
deux de ses membres ont préféré
abandonner philippe de dieuleveult
griser par l' aventure à lui voulu
continuer le récit de relance
c'est ici dans les rapides d'inga que
l'accident se serait produit mardi
dernier des rapides extrêmement
dangereux l'eau est retenu dans des
barrages hydroélectriques puis se
précipite en aval les chutes les
cascades les vagues dépassant six mètres
de haut
rendent presque impossible toute
navigation un danger telles que deux des
membres de l'expédition ont préféré
renoncer
c'est grâce à leurs témoignages transmis
par la lfp on connaît les circonstances
de la disparition de philippe de
dieuleveult et de son équipe
je continue je veux poursuivre avec moi
la scène se passe lundi soir sur une île
au milieu du zaïre essai de dieuleveult
qui parle
d'après les reconstitutions les docteurs
expédition bivouac sur cette île
épuisé par une première tentative de
franchir les rapides plus bas c'est
encore pire
le fleuve le plus puissant du monde
après l'amazone est agitée du tourbillon
de dieu le veut a sans doute dû
souligner que l'expédition avait déjà
connu des moments très difficiles
notamment en passant d'autres
remplissent surnommés les portes de
l'enfer de les participants décident
d'abandonner le mardi matin
tu vois leurs compagnons partir et
perdre immédiatement le contrôle de leur
embarcation et aux rescapés seront
récupérés plus tard à la gendarmerie sur
l'île il a fallu
alors qu'anne aussi réparé des cordes
pour regagner la rive
dans le courant est fort